the smartest and most successful people
i know started out as losers
if you view yourself as a loser as
someone who's been cast out by society
and has no role in normal society then
you will do your own thing and you're
much more likely to find a winning path
[Music]
so one thing i don't like to do by the
way when i do my books on the kindle i
skip two-thirds of them and the reason i
skip two-thirds of them is because
they're kind of embarrassing they won't
sound like good books you read they'll
sound like trivial or silly or uh
whatever but who cares i mean i don't
have to tell everybody everything i read
i read all kinds of stuff that other
people consider junk or even
reprehensible i read all kinds of stuff
that i disagree with because it's a mind
bender
i found myself in some random dark hole
in twitter the other day where i was
reading this guy's tweets like wow he's
really smart he's really interesting
mine's very clever like wait a minute
this guy is a full-blown white
supremacist i mean he's not even like
mildly a white supremacist he just
thinks like everyone in the white race
should be gone and people like me
shouldn't be allowed on the streets but
it was still fascinating and he's still
really smart and i kept reading ahead
and i read it and read it read it after
a while i built up my own sense of his
coherent view of the world and where he
was coming from but to do that i
couldn't have judged too much and i'm
certainly not going to go around
bragging to my friend hey i learned this
from a white supremacist the other day
right so to some level you almost have
to read the stuff you're reading because
you're into it and that's it
you don't need any other reason there's
no there's no mission here to accomplish
just read because you enjoy it if you
read what everybody else is reading i
mean there's wisdom that you're going to
think what everybody else is thinking so
you need the diversity and almost like
an index fund approach right where
you're going to catch the winners but
you can't really identify a lot of them
beforehand they're going to change you
as a person because so much of that is
contextual
yeah i think almost everything that
people read these days it's designed for
social approval
you know all the best sellers are about
social improvement social conditioning
if you really want to be
successful happy blah blah blah all
those external metrics you're looking
for a non-average outcome and so you
can't be reading the average thing to
your point
and
all these things are actually as old as
the hills you can go read adam smith
from the wealth of nations you could go
read benjamin franklin and his aphorisms
and understand how to live your life you
could read
charlie munger you could read
you could read charles darwin understand
evolution of the source you could read
watson and crick understand the
structure of double helix and dna but
instead what we choose to read are just
you know whatever's number one at the
airport bestseller or whatever our
friends are reading or we read i know
people who have read a hundred
regurgitated books of evolution and
they've never read darwin or they've
read they've got or think of the number
of macroeconomists and they're all out
there i think this is most of them who
have read tons of treatises and
economics but haven't read any adam
smith yeah right so
at some level you're doing it for social
approval you're doing it to fit in with
the other monkeys you're fitting to get
along with a herd
but that's not where the returns are in
life the returns in life are being out
of the herd social approval is inside
the herd so if you want social approval
definitely go read what the herd is
reading
but it takes a level of contrarianism
and saying nope i'm just going to do my
own thing regardless of the social
outcome
um to learn anything i think that's
interesting
do you think there's some sort of loss
of version there because once you
diverge
you're pushing out say there's a
gaussian distribution you're pushing it
to one of the tails
and if you feel that you're going to
lose out on that you would rather just
stay in the middle if there's a chance
that you're not going to be in the in
the fat tail for a positive
absolutely i think that's why the
smartest and most successful people i
know started out as losers
if you view yourself as a loser as
someone who's been cast out by society
and has no role in normal society then
you will do your own thing and you're
much more likely to find a winning path
so it helps to just start out by saying
oh i'm never going to be popular i'm
never gonna be accepted i'm already a
loser i'm not gonna get what all the
other kids have i'm just gotta be happy
[Music]
[Music]
you